yeah welcome to this video and we are
going g6 this is the kingside fianchetto
week so here we go um yeah here this is
interesting Black has the choice here to
play for go for Kings Indian or stay em
yeah or play play something more offbeat
going from a five year just to avoid the
regular Kings Indian which is probably
the best best move objectively speaking
interesting okay maybe just take and go
for later 96 will cost some time for
wide as the bishop has to be kept their
light e to our Knight f3 looked a bit
more natural to be able to oh wow really
but it looks strange Queen to e7 and
then what Queenie to let's start with
the move that cannot be bad really and
lets the castling on I like to Castle
get the King out of the e-file knight c6
sound is coming yet maybe 95 if I'm not
canceling I'm not sure about that it was
a what's may be possible so canceling is
good it looks a bit unnatural to be
honest this be five Bishop Jake's I know
Queenie too yeah so I don't think I want
trade Queen so let's do this and get
rook e8 into the mix
yeah that is very it's very principled
but isn't this dangerous I might even
have bishop age six set at a particular
moment really wow
Oh Bishop d6 that sets exceptionally
greedy okay so rook e8 first I want now
then look d8 maybe i can go knight c6
though you can also check out okay ruki
eight is good let's do that first
it looks very shaky all that King is
insecure it's always it's also always
sitting in bishop age six his King as no
square he has to go F for then okay so
maybe he wants to move the night on i
don't know if i go here then what Bishop
d6 maybe 96 is also good let's just do
that and not think to anything too long
losing on time is the it's the biggest
danger here the position is so good it's
um justjust one should I should just
play one other one of the good-looking
moves I'm not waste time yeah so cheek
and rook da door do I have something
better
yeah let's do that play will complete
yeah I probably had something better
earlier but well have to make sure not
to lose on time
no but that is that is not not really a
really that that clear em let's go maybe
90 for taking f2 and 95 coming
I really did not use that to the fullest
it's his opening was completely
completely unplayable but it didn't turn
out to be so bad so can I take on e 2 e
290x Queen 80 or is this too much yes
Queen III maybe I can take you for that
that's interesting actually let's let's
do that
so maybe Bishop c7 is amor I didn't see
that coming but Queen B form yeah Quinn
before it's actually okay I think but I
should have seen it I should have seen
the move in the first place Group D 898
I know chat it on maybe right light it
to Queen d2 that link will be two anyway
so um check here on me to or not I think
it should be right up check and now
where am I going there so anyway to to
really meet him if I check on a one he's
giving his getting them and I'd see one
pen getting night see one and those
nights they're both hanging
Bishop h6 is not working unfortunately
haha tricky time morning Jeff okay it's
chicken and a thought Bishop Bishop up
now look here
what is he playing now queena for a
gunite is six ok chick chick on hmm SOC
to check no I don't have to have to play
move now first and foremost not spend
time check my I'm I'm an exchange down
here right that said son blue jelly
let's take him check check check you ran
into that one check
94 is a neat little little trick so the
rook doesn't have any super great square
check here right damn that's good Kim
there Oh No c6 is tricky
yes my time my time is the problem yeah
unfortunately this is bloody bloody be
porn that he will take now unbelievable
just one can go short black resign now
I'll it's a shame after that completely
unplayable opening where did I screw
that up okay like here Bishop c7 lesson
isn't insane move but how do i how do I
actually win now maybe that was really
too lame now can the count gives Knight
g4 winning that is winning why is it
winning bishop age 6 somehow or 95 what
exactly is the point let's just say does
that okay then I have shipped III okay
of course yeah of course be takes is
just made that's the problem I'm
threatening yeah of course I'm just
threatening bishops III and when I'm
going to win the whole board actually be
takes Queen be one mate and Queen takes
betrayed Queens Knight f2 and I win a
complete rook so he has to do something
like that and then 96's is really strong
be 5695 now that that is strong we are
definitely ok so this 94 wins why does
that win so I didn't see that one why
not here I can take here okay
and again his explodes chairman ok so i
played this i just played it terribly
Knight e5 wins this is not winning it is
winning ok so where did I screw it up I
can check on d1 first instead of yeah
Jack and just take that what is the
problem here King takes Queen f5 meeting
on when you have to assign missed so
many wins it's unstable ok even that is
a wind check check I screwed it up that
was really bad so here and then Queen
your check is winning ok i added that's
actually is quite nicer if he if he
moves the king I will take him kill
mites position is check just crumbling
check check check this is unfortunately
just equal check check can you escape
check check check on the dead and it's
really weird how can I not win this it's
very difficult Knight f6 is better for
94 but I liked all those check walking
tricks but here so be five is better wow
that's be 5s Panem since before and I'm
running with dad and I have 95 maybe
this is still better from like when the
comp gives a clear black edge but I'm
not not really sure about it probably
yeah but of course I should have should
have won in the opening
this is a very weird idea why this is
absolutely not developed and just has a
has a terrible King here with long
castle so it's really a shame that I
didn't punish that okay well thanks for
watching